[Music]
in this morning Saturday sessions Punch
Brothers the acclaimed quintet has been
belting out a modern form of bluegrass
since forming in 2006
you'll hear the band perform from their
new album in a moment but first I sat
down with three of the Bands founding
members Chris Thile Gabe Witcher and
known Pakal me at reservoir Studios here
in New York the five members of Punch
Brothers
all grew up in string bands but quintet
includes Christie Lee on mandolin Gabe
Witcher on the fiddle and violin
no impecca me on banjo Chris Eldridge on
guitar and Paul Cowart the stand-up bass
you're all extraordinarily accomplished
musicians in your own right what changes
in the collaboration within the first 15
seconds of playing music with each other
it was just it was an instant just like
mind meld how did you all come together
at first well yeah this fella and I met
at a Bluegrass Festival in Southern
California called the follows camp when
I was seven and he was nine we played
with your dad's bluegrass band and they
had this gag where he would basically
play on top of a chair so he was the
same height as everyone else so good I
was like this is the coolest kid in the
whole world
fili and Witcher became friends but it
wasn't until 2006 that they began to
collaborate
[Music]
it became apparent that while we had
jammed informally quite a lot over the
years and stayed in contact that it was
probably time for us to actually get
serious and do a project that's when
they pulled in put Kel knee and Eldridge
and Punch Brothers had their first
sessions how would you describe the
music you make
I think it's American for one
it has elements of country and classic
[Music]
but with their string instruments the
band is most often labeled bluegrass
does it ever bother to you to be put in
that in that category it depends like if
we came in to the studio right now and
we were asked to sit on hay bales like
that would that's probably across the
you know across the line Punch Brothers
enjoy playing with audiences
expectations we would love to be the
band that gets you out of your musical
routine
their last album phosphorescent blues
made the top ten on the folk rock and
bluegrass charts it's really pretty
thrilling to watch what you guys can
make but what does it feel like for you
pretty thrilling like this like I
suppose the reason I'm in this band just
to have the best seat master than in the
house
[Music]
it's kind of like a you know Harlem
Globetrotters element to like how we
know each other like how we can set each
other up when it arrives and
everything's going just right there
there is this sense of being dissolved
as an individual in a wonderful way
[Music]